[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look closely and you'll see the face of
someone who just ripped their pants on
national television and handled it like
a boss
yeah i felt the energy some things
didn't go as planned but we kept moving
on
on saturday lil na's x brought all the
sexual energy
leather and skin bearing outfits from
his montero call me by your name music
video to the saturday night live stage
but ended up giving a more revealing
performance than he had planned
[Applause]
[Music]
that's when the 22 year old stepped up
to the pole to show off some moves
dropped it low and well ripped his pants
[Applause]
but lil nazex played it off and finished
up his performance like a true pro
never even flinching once to be honest
when the show wrapped he hit up social
media to weight in on the wardrobe
malfunction
tweeting quote not my pants ripped on
live on tv
later he joked i wanted to do my pull
routine
so bad this what i get lmao
he also retweeted some of the comments
and jokes about the incident
a lot of which celebrated how he handled
the mishap and how the performance
itself
still slayed had an amazing sign and the
rapper seemed to have a pretty good
sense of humor about it
sharing his own reaction to the moment
on tick tock
[Applause]
and his reaction to this fan's tweet
comparing his pan splitting moment
to spongebob squarepants pants splitting
moment
but back to snl
[Applause]
[Music]
for his second performance lil na's x
saying his new single son goes down
and the number had a more angelic vibe
complete with a smoke-covered stage
and white ensembles all around
the 22 year old dropped the video for
his song last week
just a day ahead of his snl debut better
grab your tissues cause it'll have you
all in your fields
[Applause]
[Music]
and when eti caught up with lil na's ex
in 2019
he said he isn't taking anything for
granted
i guess i'm like in a in a constant
state of you know
realization and like just like life in
general
how everything is happening for me and
just
and then you know just grateful overall